freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher koch
lang lang ist's her dass wir uns hier
gesehen haben aber es ist wieder soweit
und das hat einen ganz bestimmten grund
und ich habe heute einen ganz besonderen
gast sebastian ich würde dich einmal ins
video zu kommen hallo erstmal ein
paketbote ja da immer mit möglichst
schnell vielleicht was geht ab paar
leute von instagram wissen schon was
abgeht denn ich habe vor bisschen über
zwei wochen dieses paket hier bekommen
und da stand folgendes drauf wie die
idee ein tag persönlicher koch für den
ubs boten der die goldene plakette
geliefert hat und nicht irgendein ich
zeig dir jetzt ja auch noch mal
wiederkommen damit du sie auch mal sehen
kannst hier botschaft von youtube und
hier ist das gute stück das hast du mir
gebracht ist ja auch nämlich so
zugetragen gebracht ist ja auch der
falsche ausdruck nur weil ihr habt mich
auf der straße angequatscht ja belästigt
und sagst du warst hast du was für macht
und ich so frei geguckt ja und dann
wusste ich ach das war ja dieses youtube
ding ja ich hatte das schon mal
irgendwann in dem video gesehen dann
habe ich dich erst mal gefragt was
überhaupt macht weil ich kann genau ich
gar nicht dann hat sie was nämlich
gefragt was ich mache ich habe es mir
erzählt und am nächsten tag oder paar
tage später kam dann das andere paket
und dann dachte mir so das einfach
machen und hier sind wir heute werde ich
einen tag für dich kochen du hast mir
wirklich das stand ja auch keine gps bot
etwas nicht übertrieben dass mir so eine
liste geschickt mit sachen die du gerne
hättest ich bin kreativ geworden und sie
starten mit ihrem frühstück dann fangen
wir auch an mit dem frühstück ist gibt
motors habe ich in meinem leben noch
nicht gegessen ich bin sehr viele meiner
rezept immer bei joshua weißmann und
derartige macht sie sind unglaublich gut
aus wir machen sie heute nach wir
schnappen uns als erstes ein und geben
das in unsere küchenmaschine hinein hat
runter und schlagen das alles ist sich
verbindet dazu geben wir jetzt 160
millimeter milch dann 20 gramm
geschmolzene butter eine prise salz
sieben gramm backpulver und auch das
lassen wir sich weiter gut verbinden
wenn das schön verbunden ist gehen wir
dazu 70 gramm zucker dann kommt auch
schon der star der schau dir auf den
button ihren namen gibt nämlich moschee
kreis das ist klebreis mehr habe ich
ganz einfach einen asiatischen
supermarkt kaufen können sollte die auch
finden können und davon gehen wir 160
gramm man merkt schon wie sie sich
anfühlt dass das was ganz besonderes ist
das willst du sehr lebens entstauben
bekommen wie das aussieht bibel style
das sieht einfach aus wie so eine
divison frosting weißt du und das war
schon mit dem teig für unsere moschee
waffeln dass wir können einfach was hat
euch diese konsistenz an oh mein gott
das ist zu sexy alter also für sexy
sprite aufgestellt wo das auch nicht
einfach an wie kann etwas so schön
aussehen was so einfach zu machen war
ich würde sie fast alles gut gegangen
doch gerade so anstatt sie selbst
festzuhalten bevor der kameramann er
wirklich war auch die hand gottes
das wirklich mithalten nach dem kleinen
feld kippen wir auch den rest schon
hinein und es sieht immer noch immer
noch schön aus und das lassen jetzt ganz
einfach an der seite stehen hier ist
auch schon unser wache eisen aber wir
haben ja noch weitere charaktere für
unser frühstück nämlich bananen braunen
zucker wow wow wow wir machen
karamellisierte flambierte bahn haben
wir 60 gramm butter die wir jetzt
langsam schmelzen werden wir sollen
nicht braun werden sondern einfach schön
vor sich hin schmerzen und der dessen
kümmern wir uns hier schon mal um unsere
bananen drei stück habe ich hier geholt
ich bin kein experte wie man mir glaube
ich anregen und wenn dann so mutter
komplett geschmolzen ist geben wir auch
schon unseren braunen zucker dazu und
lassen den ebenfalls an schmelzen so
auch hier nicht zu hoch gehen mit der
hitze weil der sollen es ja nicht
verbrennen sondern einfach nur schön
schnell wenn die masse so aussieht und
eure geschichte langsam zu rauchen
anfängt ich geb dir einfach die bananen
stücke die jetzt vorgestellten habt ihr
hinein und breitet die quasi wirklich in
dieser masse einfach ein bisschen an
dass sie schön karamellisieren von der
unterseite und danach werden wir sie
stück für stück flicken und jetzt drehen
wir die bananen stück für stück haben
wir schon so eine schöne kruste bekommt
aber die die ware magic kommt jetzt
gleich erst tut mir echt aufpassen wenn
ihr mit dieser kamera arbeitet weil sich
sehr heiß und sehr klebrig verbrannt
schon so jetzt geben wir dazu 60
milliliter rum
da hast du dir wirklich abwärts
langfristig seien gründe so und soweit
es abgeklemmt ist können auch schon
ausmachen und haben jetzt unsere
wunderbaren karamellisiertem bananen
stücke war und jetzt bleibt uns nur noch
übrig unsere waffen aus zu backen also
einfach auf schneiden hier und jetzt
fühlen wir hier quasi zu zwei drittel
des waffeleisen smit
team geht ja auch noch auf merkt schon
aber das für zwei portionen beschließen
das heißt es nur noch warten dass die
waffen fertig sind so zu guter letzt
gehen wir noch ein bisschen zucker in
sahne und schlagen die einfach so wenn
die waffen fertig gebacken sollte sie
irgendwann so aussehen tragen können wir
sie auch schon herausholen
und vertont werden macht sie erst mal
hier das auge isst ja bekanntlich mittel
und der eric auch
jetzt geht es nur noch darum das ganze
schön anzurichten deshalb sehen wir uns
gleich zum essen
[Musik]
so sebastian wir sitzen jetzt also und
vor dir haben wir zwei kiko waffeln
modul ist mit klebreis mail zubereitet
also mit dem gleichen mit dem auch mit
zubereitet werden dementsprechend hat
sie eine besondere konsistenz dazu gibt
es ein werner forster und süßes sein
also matschie habe ich schon mal
gegessen weil der freundin ja und die
fand ich eigentlich ganz nah ist wird
also ich glaube du hast auch appetit und
ich hoffe du wirst auch satt davon du
kennst den spaß nicht zu viel reden
einfach mal auf sich wirken lassen da
mache ich vielleicht noch einen kaffee
den ersten eindruck kannst du uns aber
gerne schon mitteilen
ok ich versteh ich hoffe wir sehen uns
gleich die waffen sind fast aufgegessen
ich bin sehr gespannt was du zu ihnen
sagt ich bin mega voll
und ich finde sie richtig geil was ich
eben noch nicht bisher gesagt habe ist
ich bin überhaupt kein süßer zum
frühstück überhaupt nicht
[Gelächter]
sebastian hat mir so der liste geschickt
aber da ja nicht von süßen frühstück das
ist richtig genau ich habe halt nur
teigwaren geschrieben das hat er auch
erfüllt perfekt und ich war im ersten
moment recht skeptisch aber als ich den
ersten bissen lamm hat war ich echt
verlegt muss ich sagen dass dieses in
rom flambierte bananen etwas einfach
geil und dann hast du diese leicht kühle
sahne dazu diesen quatsch das ist eine
sehr geile komposition ist würde ich mir
niemals selber zum frühstück machen von
daher gebe ich nur glatte 10 von ca
dankeschön ihr merkt schon leute das mit
dem gourmet ok es ist nicht übertrieben
gewesen und dankeschön erneut für diese
differenzierte meinung ich mache auch
selbst an dieser musik nicht und weil es
draußen wirklich knusprig der und innen
drin ist er so wir ganz eigene textur so
also normale waffe ist so flach ja und
ja so ein bisschen shui und das finde
ich aber gut weil die anderen
komponenten so weit sind dann passt das
ziemlich märkte wir werden heute noch
sehr viel spaß beim super dass der
geschmeckt hat wir machen weiter mit dem
mittagessen und bekommt zum mittagessen
es gibt eine suppe und das hier ist
unser wayne character ein hokkaido
kürbis ganz einfache schnelle
kürbissuppe weil es wird herbst frische
zutaten geiles geröstetes brot kann nur
gut werden sebastian hat mir nämlich im
vorfeld gesagt dass der suppen mark und
er hat auch regional saisonal blabla
geschrieben und hokkaido ist ja bekannt
ich hab also in nrw deshalb trifft sich
das wir agieren als erstes mal unsere
möhren unsere karotten einfach ganz grob
alles was wir jetzt machen können wir
eigentlich relativ grob machen tut
nämlich am ende alles kuriert im grunde
genommen ist auch alles super einfach
wir müssen einfach karotten würfeln
zwiebeln würfeln irgendwann würfeln
kürbiswürfel und alles anbraten danach
wächst
[Musik]
sie bestimmen viele nicht wissen kann
man beim hokkaido kürbis auch die schale
essen dementsprechend schneiden wir
einfach nur oben einmal ab wir holen
nämlich die kerne raus die wollen wir
nicht mit in der suppe haben so hier ist
unser wunderschöner hokkaido kürbis so
das geht durch super easy einfach zeigt
ein zwei mal mit löffelrein alle kerne
draußen dann schneiden wir das ding
klein
[Musik]
wir befinden uns jetzt dann auch schon
beim einem lieblingsteil nämlich alles
vorbereitet dass alles schön geschnitten
man muss nur noch alles in die töpfe
werden dass das beste generell super
simples rezept heute aber trotzdem
unfassbar lecker und wir geben dazu
kürbis ihr könnt euch vorstellen da sind
sehr viel harte sachen dabei das muss
ein bisschen kirchen aber auch das geht
eigentlich schnell also wir sprechen da
von 20 30 minuten oder sonst
irgendwo dann wollen wir mal ein
bisschen durch mengen an das alles ein
bisschen angedünstet ist geben wir auch
schon unsere gemüsebrühe dazu und zwar
ein liter davon sieht schon schön aus
ist dürfte vor allem der ingwer kommt
wirklich gut durch jetzt schon und so
lassen wir das ganze ist 15 bis 20
minuten köcheln das ist jetzt schön
gekocht auch jetzt guck mal rein lloyd
ist noch leicht an blubbern und so wie
es ist für ihren wir es jetzt einfach
aber so ein pürierstab der das ganze
schön fein pürieren kann
was hier passiert ist einfach nur dass
aus dieser groben sucht jetzt eine
schöne eine sämige
wird der geruch ist supergut ja keine
frage das ist ja schon relativ ein wir
geben jetzt noch für eine etwas
differenziertere
geschmacksnote ein wenig chili hinein
jede menge super deshalb kann man da
auch ein bisschen was drauf machen und
auch das gewinnen wird sein dann kommt
schon mal vor dass man das sinnvoll
kleckert aber das ist alles nicht so
schlimm wenn am ende die so gut schmeckt
die magische zutat nämlich kokosmilch
das wäre diese sowieso schon lecker wo
sucht man noch mal so krass auch einfach
wohnen boom boom boom boom und unter
rühren ein bisschen was beweist mir noch
auf für obendrauf jetzt heben wir das
ganze einfach unter fünf liter suppe mit
zwei anschriften alles was jetzt noch
gemacht werden muss ist eine zitrone bzw
den saft einer zitrone nina hinzugeben
und das ganze dann abzuschmecken ich
wollte dazu noch ein wenig brot
[Musik]
die geheimnistuerei hat eine ende wir
haben hier wieder nicht verraten was du
bekommst also offensichtlich an die
software
kürbis kürbis könnte sagen ganz genau
welches kürbis cocos bisschen zitrone
ist auch drin lass es dir einfach
schmecken dazu habe ich noch ein
frisches sauerteigbrot an gerüstet und
probiere man dafür als erste reaktion
nicht allzu umfänglich
und ich freuen uns auf obwohl wir wollen
jetzt auf unseren teller essen und das
wo ja
also wir wasser hatten gesagt der markt
sucht nur sehr gerne deshalb dachte mir
könnte das eine gute idee sein alles mal
probiert okay wir sehen uns gleich so
neteller ist wirklich leer gefegt das
spricht fast noch ein bisschen die
sprache als hätte es dir geschmeckt ich
bin gespannt was du sagen willst ihr
glaubt gar nicht wie satt ich könnt dass
es ist es richtig geil gewesen ein traum
jetzt zu dieser kalten jahreszeit es war
eine kürbissuppe aber der clou war aus
meiner sicht dass die zitronen 1 gemacht
ja ja so was hatte ich so noch nie ein
rezept gewesen dazu ein schönes großes
saftiges fettiges droht weil was dazu
war war nur dazu gekauft aber ich gehe
ja wir uns wohl das beste was er denn
das ist das beste denn du hast es ja
noch zu bereiten ich habe so anders ist
das hatte ich meine dazu sagen und
bewertung fällt nicht schwer weil ich
jetzt schon eigentlich gerne über die cd
geben würde aber das ist vielleicht du
bist hier zu krass aber eine 9,5 ist es
schon von 9,5 ist super freut mich sehr
auch super lecker diese ganzen aromen
kann der suppe die so ganz so dezent
platziert waren aber trotzdem weise
cremigkeit da würde ich sagen hören ein
bisschen musik an ich mache mir
abendessen fertig perfekt und wir kommen
zum abendessen wir sehen für uns ein
schönes und rekord grüne spargelspitzen
und rosmarin es gibt nämlich und rekord
stark ins schwitzen und
rosmarinkartoffeln und wir fangen an
indem wir erstmal unser und rekord
salzen pfeffern und ein wenig auf
raumtemperatur kommen lassen ganz
klassisch von allen seiten mit salz und
pfeffer bestreuen schön durch wachstum
das fleisch ein gutes stück auf jeden
fall sebastian mit verraten dass er
gerne auch fleisch ist so ein schönes
steak ist dann eigentlich einfach eine
safer sache ist schon meistens stück
frischer schwarzer pfeffer kann das
schon mal unsere steak vorbereitet so
einfach es ist bereit mir ist nächstes
unsere starke schritten vor das war's
einfach wirklich nur ein bisschen mit
oliven über netzen gutem olivenöl
natürlich die kommen auf dem grill das
fleisch vom grill kümmern wir uns und
die kartoffeln es gibt natürlich dann
auch eine beilage und zwar aus marie
kartoffeln aber nicht irgendwie sondern
knusprig vom grill sebastian hat gesagt
so auf jeden fall den grill benutzt so
macht man das tun wir jetzt damit
einfach vierteln und dann drüber heute
ist der simple aber der leckere tag ist
doch wie so oft leute das ist doch dann
eigentlich das beste erdnussöl dann
kommt der rosmarin dran falls ihr euch
fragt warum er muss irgendein olivenöl
ist einfach hitzebeständiger der safer
call wenn man das ganze auf dem grill
macht backofen bei 200 grad kann man es
aber auch mit oliven wir machen
natürlich auch noch eine prise salz und
pfeffer sodann das ganze einmal schön
vermengen da könnte auch schon unsere
schale nehmen und sie auf den
vorgeheizten gegeben so
unschön das einfach aussieht das deck
ist mittlerweile schön auf temperatur
gekommen
und wir gehen jetzt zu unserem grill der
vorgeheizt ist natürlich strikt nehmen
und geben
wir müssen auf jeden fall schauen dass
unser weg schön viel kontaktfläche hat
und auch unser finger
so ist gut und so gehen wir dem steak
jetzt 23 minuten und wir flippen
das nenne ich mal eine kruste aber das
ist eine echte koste unser steak ist
jetzt fertig und wir lassen es noch ein
wenig ruhen nehmen jetzt aber direkt
unseren spargel und geben den paar
minuten einfach auf die pflanze kann
ruhig stellen hier im be fed noch ein
bisschen anbraten hin unsere mutter
zucken wir ein wenig rosmarin hinein
sagt und dann war's das auch schon fast
wir müssen nur noch anrichten
[Musik]
als mein vertrag geht zu ende würde ich
sagen würde ich auch sagen erst mal
danke schön dass du diesen sehr leckeren
wein mitgebracht was langsam klar nicht
einzuschätzen also das wirklich sehr
sehr gut und vor dir steht auch schon
das abendessen wir haben uns mühe
gegeben ist dem wein entsprechend hübsch
aussehen zu lassen ja also ich glaub
wenn du das nicht zu wollen passt was
hier schon die grünen spargel spitze
dazu haben wir und rekord in der mitte
haben wir schöne rosmarinkartoffeln
extra lange dann kommt auch schon wieder
der klassiker kamera geht raus wir sehen
uns vielleicht der teller ist leer die
weingläser aus irgendeinem grund wieder
voll trotzdem was auch du wolltest ich
bin sowas von von
regina weihnachten so ungefähr ja auf
jeden fall das highlight des heutigen
tages für mich okay ja klar dass unsere
kurz so mein lieblingsstück vom wind ab
und war auch perfekt war gespritzten
waren richtig knackig was hat auch den
rinder fed und den fleischsaft noch an
den verkäufen gegeben holy shit alter
also es war also für vegetarier ist das
nichts gewesen heute und ich muss
wirklich sagen ein super netter
gastgeber und total bodenständig und ja
so bewertungen 12 15
die kam aus dem nichts sie kam aus dem
nächsten jahr so gut ja wirklich okay
also das freut mich geistert ist restlos
leer ich würde mir noch ein bisschen
nachschlag nehmen gerne und brust leute
leute danke fürs zu sehen wir sehen uns
nächsten donnerstag wieder wenn das
nächste video kommt erstmal danke dir
dass du so spontan dabei war es das
wirklich auch eine geschichte die das
internet freiheit haben sie heute mal so
wer das ist eine geschichte die schreibt
nur köln die schreiben sie schreiben
können so dass nämlich auch also einfach
ganz genau lesen wenn ihr so ins hätte
vom ubs boden bekommt und wir sehen uns
er macht's gutschein